[Music]
without family and that's what's so
powerful about it well that was a
powerful teaser I got asked about Carrie
obviously being a big part of that about
that footage in the in the emotional way
that it ended and always being part of
this family it's hard to accept you know
I still think of her in the present
tense you know she's such an
irreplaceable part of that legacy but
the films were about triumph and tragedy
and unfortunately real life rammed
straight into our fantasy in a way that
we never could have imagined so I think
the film has an air of melancholy about
it which it doesn't deserve but that's
life isn't it
well I mean it is and exactly you never
know what comes around the corner um
Billy also her daughter in the trailer
and being sort of carrying on that
legacy you know as have you been able to
keep in touch with her oh yeah yeah I
see so much of Carrie in her that it
just it's satisfying in a way for
everyone I think for everyone involved
in the movie and and the public as well
to see the legacy passed down from a
generation I know you can't say much but
how much of the the cliffhangers they're
the questions left unanswered from a
force awakens do you think of that we
will have answers to well there'll be a
lot of questions answered but new ones
will arise but they keep you on your
seat until episode 9 thing is because if
this trilogy follows the original
trilogy the end of this movie should
leave a big cliffhanger a big twist like
a Luke I am your father kind of twist if
we're following now exactly but I don't
know that you could ever top that I was
just in a state of shock when they they
told me that that's what they were going
to do
I
[Music]